a wildfire burning out of control in
California wine country forced hundreds
of people from their homes overnight
heavy winds are driving the so-called
Kincaid fire near geyser Ville in Sonoma
County it has already burned more than
10,000 acres Jonathan Vigliotti is in
geyser Ville near the fire lines
Jonathan what are firefighters dealing
with and good morning to you you can see
how the high winds are really whipping
up these flames the embers are flying at
times it's actually been quite
terrifying we have been here for the
past few hours watching this grow at one
point we were completely surrounded by
flames and how to literally drive
through them to get to safer ground the
winds here are picking up at times to 76
miles per hour which has made it very
difficult for firefighters here with us
on the front lines to combat this at
this point 0% containment the Kincaid
fire as it's known started at about 400
acres quickly grew to 7,000 acres 300
people had to be evacuated as this fire
continues to be battled PG&E telling us
as a precaution they turned off the
power yesterday to prevent these kinds
of fires it's unclear what started this
fire right now that we can tell you as
it stands at 0% containment the concern
is structures this is a rural area we
have heard crying cattle trapped in this
fire the big concern is these flames
making it into bigger populations and
bigger communities back to you
thank you very much Jonathan Vigliotti